you transform myself into red school I
had to chop of my nose my ears and have
sued dermal implants
oh the eyes were the most impactful the
next day I woke up and went to the
bathroom to wash myself and when I was
my face and look up in the mirror it
really struck me you know it was like
wow brutal
after that we inserted these subdermal
implants in my forehead and from that
point on the project really started to
take life and that's when we decided to
do the character of [ __ ]
I want to get as far as I can go I think
the day I stop will be the day I die
I'll give up my name and give up my
legacy there might be many who come
after me but I mean the first person in
the world to achieve what I have
achieved do you know what I mean and
today I am proud to be recognized as one
of the only human beings to have
successfully embodied a cartoon
character I have an excellent
relationship with my son he sees me as a
superhero as a super dad because of
things beyond my control we have been
separated from each other for about a
year and a half two years now but now
very soon we'll be back together at the
moment thank God I've got him in
Colombia he's with his mother he's super
happy I talked to him everyday by
variable he's a kid who until now loves
me cares about me and respect me
[Music]
in eso I'm from Meraki from a very poor
neighborhood for me Venezuela is the
best you can get in the world right now
my country is going through the bottom
[Music]
but at some point we can get out of this
son artistic dictatorship and I can go
back to my country to contribute to
bringing it back to its former glory
[Music]
who didn't even think twice about it
if they fix my country no matter where I
am whatever part of the war at that
moment I'll go straight back I really
miss it my mother's died when I was very
young when I was roughly 15 or 16 years
old a meter a fool it was an impact
social and visual for all my family when
they saw me like this for the first time
but of course I've always had this
obsession with tattooing since I was
very young there are members of my
family who support me and others who are
against
[Music]
Stano new for a while this is my
business he has breakfast here lunch
you know that's how I know him and
fanatically became friends well I never
seen someone that looked like that
before so yeah it surprised my but you
know nothing more lots of people have
the delusion of things like that maybe I
have never seen someone who look quite
like him so yeah I suppose I was a bit
surprised but you know please do it
anyways how to treat people properly
person I consider him a good man Jamie
look is like I don't believe that and my
modifications make me any more or less
able to interact with people every day
[Music]
and actually I believe what I am doing
with my body is not so that other people
can understand me but rather so I can
understand other people is to
demonstrate to people that we can't
judge by appearances if your whole life
you have thought that the devil is red
with horns and the day then dude I
admire you because that will
five-year-old Thanks
[Music]